Y es entonces, cuando se está perdido o incómodo o insatisfecho,
que uno descubre quién es.
No creo que la ignorancia sea felicidad.
La ciencia ha mejorado, sin dudas, nuestras vidas
con más salud, más longevidad y vitalidad.
Siempre agradezco a los maestros que me mostraron las leyes de la física
y que me enseñaron que tres por tres es nueve.
Puedo contar eso con mis dedos
a cualquier hora del día o de la noche.
Pero cuando un matemático me dice
que menos tres por menos tres es nueve,
esa es una lógica que se parece a la confianza.
Es decir, lo contrario al conocimiento no siempre es la ignorancia.
Puede ser la maravilla.
O el misterio.
La posibilidad.
Y en mi vida, he encontrado que son las cosas que no conozco
las que me han levantado y empujado hacia delante,
mucho más que las cosas que sí conozco.
Son también las cosas que no conozco
las que a menudo me han acercado al mundo que me rodea.
Durante ocho noviembres seguidos, recientemente,
he viajado cada año por Japón con el Dalai Lama.
Y lo único que dijo cada día
que pareciera dar tranquilidad y confianza a la gente
fue "No sé".
"¿Qué va a pasar con el Tíbet?"
"¿Cuándo alcanzaremos la paz en el mundo?"
"¿Cuál es la mejor manera de educar a los hijos?"
"Francamente", dice este hombre muy sabio,
"no lo sé".
El economista ganador del premio Nobel Daniel Kahneman
ha dedicado más de 60 años a investigar la conducta humana,
y su conclusión es que
siempre estamos mucho más seguros de lo que pensamos que sabemos
de lo que deberíamos.
Tenemos, como dice de forma memorable,
una "capacidad ilimitada de ignorar nuestra ignorancia".
Sabemos —cita, fin de cita— que nuestro equipo ganará este fin de semana,
y solo recordamos ese conocimiento
en las raras ocasiones en las que estamos en lo correcto.
La mayoría de las veces, estamos en la oscuridad.
Y ahí es donde radica la verdadera intimidad.
¿Saben lo que su amante hará mañana?
¿Quieren saberlo?
Los padres de todos nosotros, como algunos les llaman,
Adán y Eva,
podrían no haber muerto, siempre y cuando comieran del árbol de la vida.
Pero desde el momento en que empezaron a comer
del árbol del conocimiento del bien y del mal,
abandonaron su inocencia.
Crecieron avergonzados y quejosos,
conscientes de sí mismos.
Y aprendieron, demasiado tarde tal vez,
que sin dudas hay algunas cosas que debemos saber,
pero hay muchas, muchas más que es mejor dejar sin explorar.
Ahora, cuando yo era niño,
lo sabía todo, por supuesto.
Había pasado 20 años en las aulas colectando hechos,
en realidad estaba en el mundo de la información,
escribiendo artículos para la revista Time.
E hice mi primer viaje real a Japón de dos semanas y media,
y volví con un ensayo de 40 páginas
explicando cada detalle de los templos de Japón,
sus modas, sus juegos de béisbol,
su alma.
Pero debajo de todo eso,
algo que no pude entender
me conmovió tanto por razones que no podría explicarles, sin embargo,
que decidí ir a vivir a Japón.
Y ahora que he estado allí durante 28 años,
realmente no podría contarles mucho en absoluto
sobre mi hogar adoptivo.
Que es una maravilla,
porque todos los días descubro algo nuevo,
y, en el proceso,
miro alrededor de la esquina y veo cien mil cosas
que nunca conoceré.
El conocimiento es un regalo invaluable.
Pero la ilusión del conocimiento puede ser más peligrosa que la ignorancia.
Pensar que conocen a su amante,
o a su enemigo,
puede ser más traicionero
que reconocer que nunca los conocerán.
Cada mañana en Japón, conforme el sol inunda nuestro pequeño apartamento,
me empeño mucho en no consultar la previsión del tiempo
porque, si lo hago,
se nublará mi mente, se distraerá,
aunque el día sea brillante.
He sido escritor a tiempo completo durante 34 años,
y lo único que he aprendido
es que la transformación viene cuando no estoy a cargo,
cuando no sé lo que vendrá después,
cuando no puedo suponer que soy más grande que todo lo que me rodea.
Y lo mismo es cierto en el amor,
o en momentos de crisis.
De repente, estamos de vuelta en ese nuevo trishaw
trajinando las amplias y bien iluminadas calles;
y se nos recuerda, en realidad, la primera ley del viaje
y, por lo tanto, de la vida:
uno es tan fuerte como su disposición a rendirse.
Al final, tal vez,
ser humano
es mucho más importante
que conocer cabalmente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)